welcome to Good Burger home of the Good
Burger can I take your order what are
you my sister is that your sister bro
wow so howdy Good Burger 2 come about
where where we find an End Dexter these
days it is running the place so you can
imagine how that might go I miss
Keenan was a surprise on the all that
panel after Amanda Bynes dropped out at
the last minute today there's news
Amanda was put on a psychiatric hold
yesterday morning she was reportedly
found roaming the streets naked and
alone in La she waved down a car telling
the driver she was coming down from a
psychotic episode then called 9-1-1 her
cell Amanda was supposed to be here as
well yeah I've just been you know
praying for her from 90210 to Buffy the
Vampire Slayer there was no shortage of
stars and reunions at 90's con Candace
Cameron Beret and Jody Sweden proved
they're still friendly even after the
Fallout over Candace's controversial
comments on traditional marriage were
each other's Rider dies you know like
nothing gets in between all of us you
know and we bicker
about each other just like any family
just like family squabble they they love
Shannon how are you feeling I'm feeling
great thank you you look fantastic
[Applause]
and I have a feeling this crowd is just
really really happy to see you this
crowd is amazing
Shannon Doherty gave a health update on
her stage four breast cancer battle she
was on hand for the Charmed panel she
didn't sit for the 90210 talk but did
post with her former castmates and how
about the ladies of Clueless recreating
this movie scene
you have to suck
as for another clueless film I think
seeing them as adults and in in their
lives as grown-ups and with children or
without children like just I think that
would be pretty living in the scene
hilarious whatever
[Music]
foreign